what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm your host
Warren and lately a lot of information
about the future of Marvel Studios on
the Marvel Cinematic Universe has been
coming out and it's getting fans really
really excited and right now the big bad
of the Marvel Cinematic Universe is not
simply one big bad but thousands of
variants of one character Kang the
Conqueror but what if I told you that
the villain of Secret Wars is not
actually going to be what you think now
the Multiverse Saga itself and Avenger
Secret Wars is really nothing like we've
experienced before yes the villain of
the Multiverse Saga is a person but
there are multiple variants of that
person essentially creating thousands of
big bats however like we talked about in
our last video there are rulers over
each other and there is essentially a
hierarchy of kings and here's the thing
about Kang the Conqueror no matter which
variant you're dealing with that one
particular variant any of them at one
given time want to be the ruler of the
Multiverse and no King trusts another
king and for Avengers Secret Wars I
think one Kang in particular is actually
going to rule and take over the
Multiverse and from what it sounds like
this variant of Kang the one that is
going to rule the Multiverse is going to
be a combination of two different
characters one of course is Kane to
conquer and the other is the beyonder
now some of you may have heard the
report before that the beyonder is going
to be a variant of King the Conqueror in
Avengers Secret Wars and there are
actually two ways two really big ways
that this could work and in fact it
actually makes sense and one of the ways
actually still kind of lets us have the
beyonder as a separate character
altogether because some fans might be a
little bit mad that Marvel would almost
essentially eliminate a character from
Marvel Comics by combining him with
another character however with one of my
theories we still get a variant of Kang
that is the beyonder but also the Yonder
as a separate character as well and I'll
explain the two different ways that this
could happen and why they actually both
make sense and either of these ways
would actually kind of give us good
variants of King the Conqueror that
would have to fight against this
ultimate beyonder Kang so let's break it
all down but first if you're new be sure
to subscribe so you don't miss out on
any of the latest videos and subscribe
and leave a comment to enter our
giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
series X A PS5 some Marvel Legends items
or some DC items the winner gets to pick
one item and we pick a winner at the end
of each month so here is what I think
would be the best way to have Kang the
Conqueror be the beyonder in Avengers
Secret Wars now for a little bit of
backstory for those who don't know the
beyonder and the race the beyonders
create pocket Dimensions outside of
space and time and they create these for
their newborn beyonders in these
universes the baby beyonder is all that
is in the universe and he is actually
the universe itself really freaky
concept to kind of grasp But ultimately
a crash would kind of enter his universe
and some energy would show him that
there was a Multiverse he would
eventually stumble upon Earth and he
realized that Earth and the people on
Earth weren't their entire universe in
fact they were part of something much
bigger their entire universe was way
bigger than just them and the universe
that they lived in itself wasn't even
the whole thing there's a whole
Multiverse that it's a part of so
whereas the beyonder completed his
Universe because he was it he found the
humans incomplete and he decided what
would complete them is desire so he
conducted an experiment and this is what
happened he took a lot of Heroes from
Earth and a lot of villains from Earth
put them essentially on different space
stations and then destroyed the earth
and the universe then told them to fight
and said whoever wins I'll make your
desires come true I'll Grant you
anything you want sort of like a genie
now it's important to note that this is
the story of the original Secret Wars
that was published in 1984 not the 2015
one but here is where King the Conqueror
comes in this is definitely something
that Kang would do you get the strongest
king of all who has actually conquered
the Multiverse and has full control over
the Multiverse go to Earth or many
different Earths and just due to simple
frustration with the Avengers because we
know from the Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania post-credits scene that
different variants of Kang know about
the Avengers and have run into them
before in fact the main king of
quantumania said that he killed many
Avengers in the past so many that he
couldn't even remember their names but
we do know that the Avengers are a
threat to King especially the Kang
Council in the post-credit scene amortis
says none of us killed him talking about
the gang from quantumania he says it was
them they're beginning to touch the
Multiverse and if we let them they'll
take everything we built so an
omnipotent King the Conqueror who has
basically made it to the End of Time who
can control time who can control the
Multiverse that Kang wanting to take out
the Avengers would make sense and also
the villains because they would get in
the way as well but here's the thing
this this variant of keng doesn't have
to be the beyonder you see in the secret
War Story ultimately Dr Doom would steal
the beyonder's power making him
essentially the strongest being in the
universe that they were in this is
something that could happen in Avengers
Secret Wars and give us a beyonder Kang
variant because Dr Doom steals the power
of the beyonder with technology and Kang
the Conqueror is somebody who can travel
all the way till the end of time he can
travel so far in the future and he could
definitely get some type of
technological advice that would give him
the ability to take the power of a
cosmic entity and this is how we could
get that variant that is Kang and the
beyonder that way the beyonder still
exist and the beyonder as a person still
exists as a separate character as well
and could come into the MCU at some
point in time now ultimately The
Avengers and Secret Wars do defeat doom
and they could also do the same in the
MCU of course taking the beyonder's
powers away from Kang and setting up the
beyonder to return in the MCU in the
future but of course the the other
option is that they could simply make
King a beyonder somehow I mean in an
infinite realm of possibilities with the
Multiverse with infinite universes being
possible maybe there was a time in a
separate Universe where Kang Nathaniel
Richards was born as a beyonder and he
could have discovered the Multiverse and
he could have discovered that there are
variants of himself trying to
essentially take over the Multiverse but
at the same time causing destruction to
the Multiverse and much like the
beyonder's Curiosity was peaked in the
secret Wars comic I'm sure the king
beyonder's curiosity would be very Peak
to find out that a version of him
thousands of different versions of him
from other universes were trying to take
control over everything and in turn in
doing so we're actually causing
destruction to everything and the cool
thing is is this way could also leave
room open for the actual beyonder
character to make an MCU debut later we
know that the beyonders are a race there
are species they're Cosmic entities and
of Kang is born as a beyonder it doesn't
necessarily mean that he is the
character the beyonder but it certainly
would make an incredible threat either
way whether he's part King part beyonder
or Kang who stole the power of the
beyonder you're essentially dealing with
a God who could literally do whatever he
wants with the Multiverse and this is
why it would be such an incredible thing
for Marvel Studios to do because this
villain would be on a level that we've
never seen before Thanos was awesome but
he needed The Infinity Gauntlet to do
his plans and when he even used The
Infinity Gauntlet to erase half the
universe it almost killed him plus not
to mention he had to actually close his
hand to use The Infinity Gauntlet he
could not use it if his hand was open
and the Russo brothers who directed the
films did confirm that and if you go
back and watch his hand is always closed
when he's using any of the stones just a
cool little detail but the beyonder a
king beyonder would not have to do any
of that he wouldn't even require a
weapon or technology for that matter he
would just simply have the power to to
do what he wants with the universe with
the Multiverse because he is a cosmic
being who has that control so this would
be a villain on a completely different
level than Thanos and it would be a
villain that all of the heroes and
villains would have to come together to
defeat it'll literally take all of them
the Fantastic Four The Avengers the
X-Men the Brotherhood of evil mutants
and even Kang variants themselves would
have to fight against Kang the Conqueror
if he was the beyonder and I do like
this twist because I think either way we
still could get the beyonder in the
future the actual beyonder not a king
variant but it would set up Kang to be a
completely dominant and all-powerful
villain and it would also kind of create
a lot of hate with the other Kang
variants because all the other king
variants have to use technology to
essentially control time and do what
they want but a Kang beyonder variant
wouldn't have to he would simply just
have that power so I would be really
curious to see the jealousy and the
anger that the other king variants would
have so these are our theories on how
Kang could appear as the beyonder in
Avengers Secret Wars let us know what
you think about it and do you have a
theory of your own about how Kang could
be the beyonder in secret Wars if you do
let us know your thoughts in the
comments down below don't forget to like
the video and subscribe and of course
you can follow us on Instagram and
Twitter as well and as always thank you
all so much for watching wolf